we're happy to say that emily radekowski
joins us for her first tv interview to
talk about her book hello author how
does that feel to you it feels crazy
it's great how does that feel yeah i
thought your book was very interesting
number one you said you didn't want a
picture of yourself on it you just
wanted the words yeah and you wanted the
words my body this is what i learned in
the book you've been brought close to
wealth and power but not true
empowerment beauty was a way for you to
be special
you still get a kick out of your
instagram followers when they like
something all women are objectified and
sexualized to some degree you just
thought you would do it on your terms so
when i read this emily i thought she's
very confident clearly but you also seem
to be
conflicted and it was a complicated
process true for you yeah i mean i think
my early 20s i really thought of myself
as kind of hustling and working the
system and saying okay i know what i can
get from becoming a model and from you
know using my body to to have fame and
success um and i even called it
empowerment i mean um i was in the
blurred lines video that was my kind of
big breakthrough moment
and i told everyone that that felt like
an empowering experience but i think
that as i've gotten older i've realized
it's a little bit more complicated and i
feel a responsibility to tell young
girls that and share that with them and
what have you learned when you say
because you were you were out there
saying look
i think people were taken aback by by
your position at that time what have you
learned that made you change your mind
yeah i think that um i would be wrong to
say that it's just simply empowering to
be to capitalize on your sexuality and
your beauty as a woman i think that
ultimately you're trying to appeal to
men and that's you know what that
example that we were just talking about
blurred lines kind of shows and it's why
i included it in the book
so people should read the book because
we're going to just scratch the surface
very detailed layered nuanced and you're
clearly very conflicted about it um
the new york times book critic molly
young uh got touched on this ambiguity
at the center of the book which is we're
in a world where women are exploited and
you've taken your power and now
in their words exploit yourself and then
the kind of question is is that progress
i don't think that exploiting myself is
uh progress at all i think that it just
offers me some kind of control actually
the only time i feel like i've
experienced empowerment is through
writing this book and through telling my
story and um through even just making
something creating something that feels
like real power but why wouldn't you
argue you're not exploiting yourself
yeah oh no i mean i think that i'm using
my sexuality i don't know if somebody
can exploit themselves i think that
that's what control means um but i think
that definitely i've capitalized on my
image and and my success the point that
the book reviewer was making is that
you've you've you're continuing in this
business of making money off of your
appearance while at the same time
criticizing that whole industry yeah so
you're in both positions at the same
time i think it's really important i
think politicians are a perfect example
of that um they're criticizing the
system and they're still working within
it because you want it to change um and
i think that you know as somebody who
you can google and look at at my
instagram and see all this glamorous
kind of really i think powerful success
fame um it's really important to give
give people the full story now vanity
sales in america we know this it's it's
part of the american dream for some um
what would be your advice to young women
out there that look in the mirror and
say you know what i'm pretty yeah a nice
body um i can sell this a little bit
but also understanding that there could
be a slippery slope yeah listen i don't
fault young girls and i would never tell
a young girl i would never shame them
about the way that they dress or how
they might try to work the system and
and kind of be that's just the reality
of the world we live in that being said
i don't want them to just think that's
going to be a beautiful pathway with
like flowers and you know all that
careful yeah it's more complicated than
that and there's a lot of ways that you
can be hurt especially if you are naive
um i was saying to gail earlier i think
i was kind of defiant and i really
wanted to believe that you know i was
the example of of a woman empowered that
if this was feminism that you could use
your body to to have fame and success
and in some ways that's totally true
in other ways um you know there's
examples in the book where i i didn't
feel empowered um because it's more
complicated than just that yeah and you
talk about your life in high school
things that have happened to you talk
about modeling assignments stuff that
you wish you had been told in high
school i read your stuff i said wish i
had been told that in college that hey
dude i don't owe you anything
but you know as you mentioned you you
became an overnight seemingly sensation
after the blurred lines video in the
book we learned that during that time
during that photo shoot a robin thicke
groped you and you you talk about that
and i think if people focus on that
they're missing the point but i i do
want to talk about that for just a
second because you said in that moment
he took everything because you were
having a great time you admit you were
prancing around you were being making
goofy faces and really enjoying it but
in that moment he reduced everybody you
thought all the women on the set to what
yeah um i mean i think that that set is
such a good example of what i'm talking
about because it was all women it was a
female director cinematographer i felt
so comfortable compared to other jobs i
was doing at 21 it was i was having fun
yeah i was really having fun um and then
in that moment all of a sudden we
realized who was in charge because there
was no stopping there was no you know if
we had stopped the set there's another
prettier girl who would be happy to be
in my place um and i think everybody
who's working there even though we felt
this connection it was like well robin
thicke's in charge and um
you know i don't this was not a gotcha
moment in any way i'm not interested in
canceling anyone for me it was telling
the whole truth of the reality of that
experience because for so long
everything that i said was it was really
fun which you know by the way it was
awesome yeah on the flip side
but she's planting around and there's
videos where you know you are topless
and they go well what do you expect and
to that you say yeah i mean i think
that's a shame i don't think that women
um no matter what they're wearing or
what they're doing should be treated
that way
so emily how do we how do we change this
system uh you mentioned that you work
within it so you have the power to make
it better
what does better look like i mean i
think it's a cultural shift there's
obviously ways that we can protect
models but it's a really complicated
industry because it's it's just about
using women's bodies to sell products um
so ultimately there's it's always going
to be a level of objectifying i think
though having respect for these young
women offering them as much control as
we can possibly give them that's huge
but i think just in general i'm
interested in talking about women in
general not just the industry and how we
treat young girls how we uh teach them
and and all kinds of subtle ways that
they kind of are obligated to be um
really sweet never let that let what
they need and and protect themselves
being known we should say i want to make
it clear robin thicke has not responded
to the comments that you've made about
what happened on the set but i want to
wrap it up with my favorite line of the
book was how you ended it talking about
the birth of your son who you said came
out of your body yeah once again my body
so you're a mother now to a son yeah
what will you teach him
um six months eight months eight months
today oh birthday today um
yeah thank you i'm gotta pull out a
candle for him um now you have an
opportunity to teach him yeah listen i
think women and men can benefit from
understanding these power dynamics
understanding the ways that i think that
you know sometimes men feel um
intimidated they feel like they have
something they have to prove there's a
lot of things that are really hard for
men too i think toxic masculinity is bad
for for everyone um and i really want to
take that pressure off him and also make
him aware of the way that he can he can
hurt women and in certain situations
it's really can you teach him it's
really a terrific book uh
it's insight into into a world that most
people struggle to imagine and you've
done it really well it's been read for a
long time oh thank you i really
appreciate that thank you emily
rodriguez
congratulations thank you guys people
got gone from how do you say her name to
what is that jay to emily ratakowski her
book is call my body it goes on sale
tomorrow wherever you like to buy your
books you've got lots of options if you
or someone you know is seeking sexual
assault counseling or resources you can
call the hot the national hotline the
phone number is
1-800-656-4673 again that number is
1-800-656